ارتفع عدد الشهداء الفلسطينيين بنيران
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه الى
السته بينهم اثنان استهدفته ما مسيره
اسرائيليه فجر اليوم في حي المنشيه في
مخيم نور شمس بطول كرم هذا وافاد الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني بان الاحتلال يمنع
الاسعاف من دخول المخيم لنقل مصابين رغم
التنسيق عبر الصليب الاحمر وقد سقط الشهيد
الثالث برصاص الاحتلال ظهر امس السبت خلال
محاولته عبور جدار الصل العنصري غرب بلده
دير الغصون وقبل ذلك اعلن مستشفى الرازي
في مدينه جنين استشهاد شاب متاثرا باصابته
بشظايا قذيفه من مسيره اسرائيليه في الحي
الشرقي من المدينه خلال عمليه اقتحام وسقط
شهيد اخر برصاص الاحتلال خلال مواجهات في
بلده ومخيم دير عمار شمال غرب رام الله
ليله السبت فيما سقط شهيد سادس برصاص
الاحتلال خلال مواجهت في بلده بيت امر
شمال مدينه الخليل مساء
السبت وقد افاد مراسل الجزيره بان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اقتحمت مخيم العروب
شمال الخليل الجنوبيه الضفه الغربيه كما
اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الليله
الماضيه مدينه يطا جنوب مدينه الخليل
ودهمت مواقع عده في المدينه وقامت بمصادره
عدد من مركبات المواطنين
الفلسطينيين
واقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مدينه
نابلس شمال الضفه الغربيه ودهمت احياء
الفاطميه وفيديا والمخفيه والاتحاد
واعتقلت عددا من الشبان وحصرت مستشفى
الاتحاد ينضم الينا من امام مستشفى ثابت
ثابت في طول كارم مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار
كما ينضم الينا من امام مستشفى الاتحاد في
نابلس مراسل الجزيره محمد خيري ابدا معك
ليث ولو ترصد لنا المشهد من حيث
انت نعم يعني نحن الان نتواجد امام مخيم
نور شمس في هذه الصوره التي تظهر في على
الشاشه في هذه الاثناء حيث لا تزال
العمليه العسكريه لجيش الاحتلال متواصله
حتى هذه اللحظه نرصد في هذه
الصوره عدد من الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي لا تزال تجوب شوارع
المدينه
والمخيم مخيم نور شمس حيث لا يزال
الاحتلال يطبق الخناق حتى هذه اللحظه وما
يزيد عن عره ساعات على العمليه العسكريه
والتي لا تزال حتى هذه اللحظه متواصله
اصوات الانفجارات والاشتباكات لا تكاد
تهدا في مخيم نور شمس مخيم طول كرم بعد ما
يزيد عن 10 ساعات على بدء هذه العمليه
العسكريه عدد كبير من الاصابات وايضا عدد
من الشهداء ارتقوا خلال هذه العمليه
العسكريه والاحتلال لم ينسحب حتى هذه
اللحظه قبل قليل كان هناك انسحاب لبعض
الاليات العسكريه لكن الاحتلال لا يزال
يتمركز تحديدا على المداخل الرئيسيه خلال
الليله شهدت منطقه المنشيه اشتباكات مسلحه
وانفجارات عنيفه على وقع العمليه العسكريه
وايضا يعني
في عده انحاء من المخيم على واقع ذلك يعني
كان هناك ايضا اشتباكات في مخيم طول كرم
وايضا اقتحامات من عده مناطق منها 104
وحاجز 104 او ما يسمى بتسني عوز وايضا من
حاجز عناب عشرات الاليات العسكريه التي لا
تزال حتى هذه اللحظه متواصله في المدينه
وهناك حالات عديده من الاعتقال نف نفذت
منذ ساعات الليل وحتى هذه اللحظه حملات
مداه ومداهمات لعده منازل اعتقالات واسعه
في صفوف الفلسطينيين والعمليه العسكريه
حتى هذه اللحظه متواصله نرصد في هذه
الصوره المخيم مخيم نور شمس الذي لا يزال
الاحتلال يحاصره حتى هذه اللحظه على الجهه
الاخرى منطقه جبل النصر الذي وقعت فيه
اشتباكات خلال الليله وايضا كان الاحتلال
واجد فيه بكثافه على الجهه الاخرى لو ينقل
لنا المصور الصوره هناك
حيث يعني منطقه المنشيه التي شهدت
الاشتباكات المسلحه والتي لا تزال حتى هذه
اللحظه متواصله لربما نرصد في هذه الصوره
الدخان الذي يتصاعد حتى هذه اللحظه من
منطقه حي المنشيه على وقع انفجارات واسعه
واستهداف من قبل الطائرات
الاسرائيليه المسيره وايضا يعني لا تزال
ايه ال الاليات العسكريه ايه تجوب شوارع
المخيم وتحديدا مناطق ساحه المخيم مناطق
المنشيه وجبل النصر العمليه العسكريه
متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه على ما يبدو انه
حتى الان لا يوجد انسحاب وانما هو يعني
تحرك واعاده تمركز لبعض الاليات العسكريه
في محيط المنشيه وايضا مداخل الرئيسيه
لمخيم نور شمس هذا الدوار ما يسمى بسيف
ابو لبده او الشهيد سيف ابو لبده حيث
يتواجد اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه في محيط
هذا الدوار وتتمركز عشرات القناصه في
انحاء متفرقه من محيط المخيم حتى هذه
اللحظه لا تزال الاليات وجنود الاحتلال في
داخل المخيم في بعض انحاء المخيم منعت
طواقم الاسعاف من الوصول ونقل الاصابات
حتى ساعات الصباح حيث تم نقل ايه حتى هذه
اللحظه على على الاقل ما يزيد عن اربعه
شهداء الى مستشفى ثابت ثابت الحكومي فيما
لا يزال عدد اخر من بينهم شهداء وجرحى
داخل المخيم